[Music]
so this will be an adoption match right
yeah where i will be adopting you
yes that's how this is going to work
that's correct and uh the time control
so we were thinking about some odds the
odds that would uh more or less equal
our chances
i had a match once with alexander
bortnick
and
i lost
almost all my games not all but almost
all it was one to five so today we were
thinking of uh
30 seconds to
three minutes
30 seconds to three minutes and i need
to win 10 in a row
yeah do you think that's gonna
that's gonna be the case i think it's
gonna be very tough i've done that with
botez and i have not succeeded too many
times
because the problem is it's like
sometimes she gives me a draw cushion
like i get one draw are you inclined to
be generous
but wait troy is like in my favor right
if we do it without the draw then a draw
wins the match for you like a single
draw wins the match for you because it's
no adoption technically
so you want one draw chance right one
draw chance yeah
okay i can give you that chance yeah for
sure thank you
yeah
yeah very generous
all right and now i'm gonna add time
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
and this is basically impossible odds
but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe h3 and queen okay this is maybe
slightly better for white
[Music]
okay i'm not blundering my queen right
she's gonna go find d7 i think
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i allowed our knights to get those gucci
forms
[Music]
uh-huh
[Music]
[Music]
oh i had to win
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
that's just how i win most of my games
[Music]
oh my god
i'm i have zero
zero um
shame about flagging in this kind of
match
okay guys you do realize i have to adopt
dina right it's not the other way around
i was winning there with rook takes g5 i
i kind of lost my focus there
i'm gonna play something i can play fast
[Music]
hopefully she that tilts her a little
bit
[Music]
the end game looks okay for me
i think it's bad
[Music]
get the sense to dina's
huge endgame
[Music]
don't have a good handle on what her
style is
yet
[Music]
i'm probably worse
[Music]
[Music]
not good
now i've stabilized
i mean this is virtually impossible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right we got her there
thank you chess square larry bird's
mustache two very close games
i gotta i gotta win earlier than the nbn
game because she's gonna get me in one
of these
yeah that was good speed though
these are underrated obviously
yeah rated would be
[Music]
all right two
let's go
[Music]
well it's not as easy as just playing
fast i'm i'm bad but not that bad you
know you can't just like make random
moves against me and flag me in when i
have 40 seconds
which i just watched two days ago okay
i'm repeating this opening this got me a
really good position
and she can play bishop g4 if she wants
but
[Music]
so
yeah i don't like this
okay if i let her take
if she takes she opens the f file for me
[Music]
so
[Music]
just tilting
now i'm confident i can win this
now i'm feeling
confident i just got a not blender my
queen here that's the one thing
i'm gonna not do
so she goes out five i'll go queen h
four queen h5 queen h4 finish four
h4
i feel like she'll go out five
i mean i'll go here anyway
just
threaten mate
g6 i'll go
here get this knight around should go
knight g6 win h5
knight f4 will take it
okay
[Music]
plenty of time we got plenty of time
plenty of time
[Music]
i'm not sure which piece to take with
but i'll just stick with the fish
okay we don't really want to play a
gaffy also wins on the next move
[Music]
but i gotta make a move here
okay this one's a queen that's it
okay good one
very good great start
you know now d now ding now
dan is definitely winning
[Music]
ricardo is experiencing the wartnick by
the way
damn dino
[Music]
all right
okay gathering myself let's go with
sicilian
i think she's a c3 player
i'm sure i don't remember
[Music]
clarissa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mighty three i'll take it c3 i'll go
before i think sugar rook b1
actually oh
okay that's fine
oh i guess i'll take with the pawn
um
what is this
no no no no that was very bad uh oh oh
no that's not good i gotta go off six
now
i blundered i i didn't like didn't what
she didn't register properly okay now i
gotta save this
no this is lost
one mistake that's the problem
[Music]
sadly
i'll try my best
[Music]
wait
i shouldn't run on the fork
[Music]
oh that's tricky i missed that
now i got a flagger
do
so
so
she got me
gg
yeah i know i mean there's i mean
there's no way there's no way i can win
scenario these odds i came very close to
flagging her that i shouldn't have i
should have probably taken this pawn
f6 pawn instead of the c3 pawn but
you can tell me how you feel you know
you played well i mean i could tell i
wasn't going to make it after the first
game
but
in this game you almost almost did it
like
you should have like taken like one pawn
yeah i should have taken up six vf4 pawn
and and then it's like i wouldn't make
it
yeah i didn't for some reason i thought
i could fork your queen but once i
realized i messed up when you played
queen quinn h4 it didn't register i
accidentally played e6 instead of f6
yeah once you played bishop g5 i knew it
was over
yeah you know what i didn't get like i
saw your trick like knight f3 and i like
told myself like why he why is he giving
me away the dark squared bishop that's
like shouldn't have done that that was a
bad decision given the
given the time time control
yeah yeah
no okay so
you were talking yourself down
talking myself down
no you're you're a really good blitz
player
what does it mean
i mean you're not slow at all
i didn't get the sense that you were
slow
um
that's called a compliment
okay okay because yeah i i don't i don't
exactly see where but okay no but i'm
i uh yeah it was super hard but the
first game wow it was so beautiful how
you flagged me
well that's just what i've this is just
what i make my career off of
just basically mouse speed
wow right so um um
shall we um continue
just for the um sake of the owner or
it's um
it's like i'm down to just play six more
if you want i'm just down to play six
more games and then just just for fun i
mean you won the match but
we can just do up to ten games just to
like
you know yeah
yeah
yeah let's see if i can like equalize
the score
okay okay watch what's your language
there
uh now now now we gotta finish the match
now that you said that
um i mean it's you're only leading two
points and we've got six more games so
uh
yeah
all right game on game on okay let's go
let's go without you
all right dina
you're gonna regret saying that
at what time odds do you think you win
the adoption match i think
you i think i would be a favorite to win
an adoption match at
two to three
i think at two to three i'd give it 50
50 odds because you have to understand
just beating 10
against anybody decent when you've got
almost no time is just
you're you're going to just
statistically make a mistake in 10 games
like
there's no question about it
okay let's play the goldman
or the narrow con
okay dina knows the like annoying line
[Music]
knight b6 yeah this is the line and the
bishop d3
and then you can grab this pawn but then
knight e2 it's a little dangerous for
black
d5 probably yeah okay this end game is a
little better for white
[Music]
now we're demonstrating all the pieces
here
well knight g5 was so much stronger oh
no
[Music]
excuse him what else is now
dina has about an hour to figure that
out though that's the issue also
i can set traps but they're not really
going to work
[Music]
should be 700
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know why i did that
dina is sharp she's not missing
i'll try any fly here
so
[Music]
this one i'm gonna win
okay i'm just like up on time so i can
just play chess shut up alexa
goodbye
[Music]
okay good good good one good job good
job i mean i had time to spare too
all right all right this is i'll
equalize the score
we'll see about that
okay let's go e5
there's another slime
d3h64
okay now we can free move
[Music]
yeah i should have maybe kept my bishop
[Music]
get a frame of that
oh no no no i blunted my knight
i just didn't see that
oh she she didn't see that either
there's a weird blind spot there with
queen d1 takes g4 i don't know why
that's hard to see but it's hard to see
this is the elephant gambit
[Music]
i mean
yeah if she took that it was over
so bishop sees
okay
um oh i'm too slow
[Music]
[Music]
oh no i've loaded h6 i
[Music]
i'm not taking any of my stuff
and i'm still in trouble wow
okay this is complicated though
gina should have won that with this one
but i'm gonna win it now
[Music]
i hope i'm gonna win it
okay no primos no primos
[Music]
i can remove this
nice
all right tina let's go
ggo
[Music]
all right
yeah you guys can follow her stream
at twitch.tv
the bell and kaya
because she streams sometimes her sister
streams as well on that channel
[Music]
[Music]
okay
time
okay her sister i think is like 2 000 i
want to say
whoa thank you for the subs
[Music]
appreciate it
what is g6 is that a move
i don't know if that's a move
[Music]
thank you falling walls appreciate it
yeah no i will never forget it either
that is honestly one of the iconic
twitch
moments i can't even do it
it's it's
nothing better than that
then you lost
danny lost and you lost damn lost he
lost
[Music]
now that i'm relaxed i'm playing better
i think
all right dina
you're gonna regret this
all right cantaloupe
an example of how weird russian is is
d-i-n-a means cantaloupe or what's that
vegetable called but it's it's
pronounced deena
so the difference in tina and denia
[Music]
melon melon
all right
damn girl
oh she's being annoying
so good here
are you calling me melon
the knight hmg5
no we're not giving away anything here
yep
what's up hess okay um
well let's add some clock to dina
three minutes see now that there's
nothing on the line i'm playing really
well
i i guess she's subconsciously relaxed
as well
okay now the party can begin let's play
the outgun
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
okay
i hope she doesn't go e5 or something oh
oh no
i forgot about that move
i'm gonna pretend this is a gambit
i completely forgot a4 was the thing
that was a bad primo i think you can
sell
but it's okay i think i can this
particular position i think i can
mix it up
i don't think it's that simple
despite the okay now i have two pawns
for the piece it's a game
this is this is a game
[Music]
[Music]
ah fudge
fudge
now i'm gonna lose i think
thank you koobygami
how am i gonna swindle this now
okay i'm not sure the trades are
actually that make it that easy for
white to win this though
[Music]
or maybe they do no they they definitely
do
oh dinosaur gameplay is pretty damn good
i have to say
[Music]
trying to infiltrate
and i really hope she misses a4
that gives me a small chance
she sees
i can dream of c4 that's a safe pre move
not good not a good move there by dina
oh my god i'm am i gonna win this i
think i'm gonna win this
yeah i'm going to win this
daniel brooke with webcam
yeah no no no no no dina you don't have
a chance here
now i got you there we go
oh that's painful
two more
two more ladies and gentlemen
i mean i had like one trick there the
c4a4 thing bye bye bye bye
dm girl
build
yum
all right
let's go c4
okay
you dr krieger
yeah this is actually the correct line
for black
some kind of stuff
bishop h6 first is better who knows
i think this is a safe primo
mr pefe i think she's gonna play
i have knight g6 also as an idea
yep
no but this is bad i don't know why i
did that
i should have just taken maybe
now i think she can maybe take who knows
no maybe this is not bad
um
crap that's a good move
ah she found a good defense
when i better have this move
okay we can remove this
um
no she traps my queen oh my god
that's not good
no
oh that's such bad luck there
that my queen was simply trapped
now i got a win-win down
i'm gonna win
i think i'm gonna win
jesus
oh my goodness that's crazy
and i actually tricked her over the
board
like that wasn't all flag
that must hurt
[Music]
okay i don't this knight c3 stuff look
at she plays nine after this time
queenie too damn
here
let's go f5 probably bad but whatever
[Music]
no no no no no no no
i thought she was gonna play bishop
where i was
positive ah
rar
wait this is not over
got this pin going
this is a game
very much still a game
classic
it's classic dania
um
uh oh
[Music]
and now this is trouble
this is trouble
i have no idea what i'll do if she plays
queen e4
yeah i have no moves
no this is made
yeah i mean i prime of g i pre-moved g5
i didn't think she would go f4
yeah good game
okay
good games ggs especially the last one
i don't buy do you do them purpose
no no i swear i didn't i didn't expect
that f4 i thought you'd play the only
the only moments in the match you think
on the move you hang a mate in one
no no i i honestly didn't know what to
do i was completely i mean i'm
completely lost
yeah but you also like kind of hang your
phone in one
no i mean i i just didn't i didn't see
what to do because you're threatening
bishop e4
and when when i hung a piece i i was
confident you played bishop f4
uh to wish i wanted to respond g5
f4 i should have played knight q4 and i
would have crushed you on that diagonal
right so i think like
regardless of the result game wise i
like i was standing at for half of my
for half of match points
yeah i mean you were winning probably 50
of the games that
you lost
yeah so uh so it's all because of the i
mean i want the i want the match so i'm
i'm happy obviously the mission
accomplished i mean right what is the
adoption but but like
if it wasn't for your for your best
friend for the
master uh
charlotte
yeah that i
could have easily equalized but that's
another story but he was he was
distracting in the chat
yeah
of course right that's classic
i felt like in a way you know i felt
like i was playing against an engine
oh you know during the match
yeah but you weren't cheating right i
was i always have stock for shopping on
the other home on the other monitor yeah
right well stop wishing your hand i
generally
like on your turn i try to think of
tactics and and little tricks or like
sequences of moves that i can play
really fast
and then i i think i i was pretty
accurate in predicting what you were
going to do
probably because we have a similar style
similar style i don't know traditional
player positional player okay i kind of
misjudged i mean when you played e4
i was like okay you're gonna crush me
with mating attacks every game you mean
move number one e4 one move number one
yeah no but okay actually my case is
really complicated because i always
think that i'm a positional player but
every single coach of mine says me that
i am a dynamic player so it's uh maybe
you're right there
yeah at least i mean i'd have to have a
bigger sample size obviously but
no that was kind of interesting
but that was uh what was funny in this
game like just like the same in the last
game when you took that when you gave
the bishop for the pawn on e5 i had the
exact same feeling like oh boy that guy
is giving away a strategical piece in
order to win a silly pawn and he's gonna
be punished and it happened like you
know naturally no you played you didn't
give me a chance after that
yay
right well
tanya i
really want to thank you for this
opportunity to finally meet you to
finally
accept my challenge with all those years
of me
beating the punching ball i finally
could beat the reason i'm honored please
please continue um it was it was a
pleasure to play you and
the next time i just gave you this um
these odds you know to make you feel
good but next time
the real me is going to come out so
beware
so no odds next time i will take you
just like this
oh odds are fine but i'll uh
you know this was this is the sort of
appetizer round
right appetizer i like the sound of that
um so yeah anyways i won't i won't keep
you will you keep streaming just in case
like when i finish
i'll throw you the rain yeah i will i'll
keep a little bit here analyzing the
games also um celebrating and most
likely celebrating the victory with our
with my chat and uh nice
yeah and uh enjoying the um this uh very
neat moments of having
punched the real dania
well i hope you
i hope you enjoy the moment i uh
yeah wish your chat the very the best
and if you're still street if you're
still streaming when i'm done i'll i'll
get through the raid
thank you so much uh likewise and um one
last thing i've got uh
your
your
uh best friend robert has in my chat uh
congratulating me on my victory so he's
already abandoning me i see
yeah you saw this trying to destroy your
friendship a little bit here and there
oh he's doing a great job of it
right okay
thank you so much thank you dina that
was a lot of fun and uh yeah
revenge revenge soon
absolutely all right dina we'll talk
soon
talk soon have a good stream bye thank
you bye
hope you enjoyed
see you guys later